bonjour tout le monde bonsoir tout le
monde
j'ai une petite voix ce matin je me suis
réveillé avec la moitié de ma voix donc
j'espère que vous m'entendez
ok super donc je me représente pas tout
on m'a assis bien présenté que je ne me
suis pas reconnu
alors
[Musique]
discipline beats
c'est notre début c'est pas ça qu'on
commence parce que c'est la première
chose qui m'est venue en tête quand j'ai
quand j'ai pensé à ce à ce TEDx et à ce
que j'avais envie de de partager au
cours de ce texte c'est la première
chose aussi dans la mesure où même quand
ça m'est arrivé en tête j'ai eu du mal à
traduire tout de suite mais bon au fil
du temps je pense que je suis arrivé à
une traduction du type la discipline
vient à bout de tout chef Maxwell
je suis bon ouais pas mal ok alors
j'espère que quand je j'utilise le terme
de discipline vous n'avez pas en tête
des choses horribles les sacrifices la
souffrance non
non ok parce que ah si parce qu'en fait
la discipline on est tous passé par là
discipline on a appris à écrire avec de
la discipline on apprend à écrire avec
de la géométrie en faisant des traits et
lié à ça comment le petit garçon arrive
finalement à écrire c'est avec de la
répétition la répétition est une grande
composante de la de la discipline et à
propos de répétition j'ai un autre
exemple pour vous
je pense que vous pourrez penser qu'il y
a du Google Translate dedans maintenant
j'essaie de me la jouer un peu après
l'anglais l'espagnol quoi voilà je parle
beaucoup de langues
mais en réalité ici vous avez un autre
fruit ou un autre exemple de discipline
ça fait un peu plus de 500 jours en fait
que chaque jour je fais un petit cours
d'espagnol
j'utilise une application
d'apprentissage de de de langue et
chaque jour je fais un petit cours que
ce soit 5 minutes 15 minutes 10 minutes
parfois une heure je
j'apprends et l'application m'a dit
dernièrement justement que j'avais
appris plus de 2000 mots je m'en suis
absolument pas rendu compte au cours de
de cette de ces 18 derniers mois et
alors je ne suis pas encore prêt à avoir
une conversation avec Raphaël Nadal ça
c'est sûr mais je vous promets que si
Pénélope Cruz vient me parler je serai
capable de lui de lui dire voilà
Pénélope
ma femme n'est pas encore arrivé
dites-lui que c'est pour plaisanter mais
je serai capable de je suis aujourd'hui
capable de pouvoir lire
correctement en espagnol
alors qu'est-ce qui maintient une
personne un homme 500 jours d'affilée
sans interruption
à apprendre l'espagnol parfois je suis
en soirée avec mes copains je me rends
compte que ah mince je n'ai pas fait mon
cours d'expaniol donc je repars je le
fais qu'est-ce qui maintient cela est-ce
que c'est la la possibilité
d'être prêt le jour Pénélope se présente
ou tout simplement à partir pour un
objectif tout simple réussir à parler
espagnol la prochaine fois que je serai
en Espagne et c'est là qu'on comprend
qu'en fait une autre composante de la
discipline c'est vraiment l'objectif la
discipline se nourrit vraiment de
l'objectif c'est l'objectif qui met ses
disciplines en mouvement et pendant que
je vous dis ça en fait je
repense à ma mère qui qui avait une pas
si expression qui me disait tu peux tout
avoir mais pas tout en même temps dans
dans cette phrase le tout avoir en fait
est aussi simple que voici l'objectif
que tu dois te fixer voilà comment tu
dois te projeter voilà ce que tu dois tu
dois tu dois atteindre et pas tout en
même temps c'est quels sont les efforts
que tu mets entre temps pour y arriver
qu'est-ce que tu peux faire comme
sacrifice pour pour y arriver donc j'ai
grandi avec ces idées et par exemple
quand j'ai démarré ma vie de jeune
adulte la première fois que je voulais
aller en vacances tout seul j'ai dû
économiser pendant un an pour pouvoir
m'offrir des vacances de trois semaines
j'ai dû économiser pendant deux ans pour
pouvoir m'offrir ma première voiture
d'occasion qui d'ailleurs allée chez le
mécanicien de moi plus tard
et donc c'est pour ces raisons en fait
c'est dans ce principe que
s'inscrit le premier slogan du défier
épargne le défier épargne disait épargne
et réalise tes projets et donc pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas le défi épargne
je veux en parler je vais pas venir 600
petit placement produit quand même
je suis dans la pub alors
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas le défi
épargne le défi épargne étant programme
d'éducation financière qui aide à
prendre conscience de l'importance d'une
vie maîtrisée financièrement parce que
je pense fondamentalement que qui
maîtrise ses finances
maîtrise sa vie et la première chose
qu'on fait dans le défi épargne c'est de
définir soi-même son objectif 500
000 francs un million cinq deux millions
et demi on définit son objectif annuel
et une fois que c'est fait le programme
va diviser en défi financier aléatoire
que vous recevrez tous les lundis pour
vous pousser à atteindre cet objectif
que vous avez défini en début en début
d'année mais comme on a compris que une
année c'est très long
régulièrement au bout de quatre semaines
il y a des récompenses parce que on se
focalise aussi beaucoup sur l'objectif
final mais dans la discipline autant la
répétition et l'objectif sont importants
reconnaître son avancée et son et ses
éléments
de croissance et tout et tout aussi tout
aussi important et on a aujourd'hui de
nombreux participants qui disent à quel
point ce défi là à une importance dans
leur vie comment ça impacte leur vie on
voit des gens qui disent je ne suis
jamais je ne suis jamais arrivé à ce
niveau d'épargne malgré tout le temps
que j'ai passé salarié ou qui s'étonne
eux-mêmes du niveau d'argent ou du
niveau de revenu qu'ils ont parce que
ils ont intégré de la discipline dans
leur dans leur vie et même on va aller
plus loin on a on aura ceux qui qui
utiliseront la discipline financière
pour l'appliquer dans leur vie au
quotidien donc la discipline qu'on peut
avoir n'importe quel moment nous sert et
nous permet de grandir nous permet de
voir nos efforts nous transformer
nous-mêmes ce qui m'emmène vraiment à
reconnaître et à dire à quel point la
discipline est surtout avant tout une
question d'amour
de l'amour pour nous-mêmes
la distance qu'il y a entre la personne
que nous sommes aujourd'hui et celle que
nous avons envie d'être demain
réside dans la discipline et j'ai un
autre exemple pour vous
avant j'étais rond
sur la photo de gauche
je faisais 102 kg bon c'est pas que je
suis devenu un peu plus carré triangle
ou plus mince mais bon quand même
j'étais rond
et j'ai décidé à un moment donné de
m'aimer je veux dire de reprendre ma vie
en main et de perdre à un an d'écart 21
kg
dans l'intervalle mon pour ceux qui se
demandaient à quoi je ressemble son
barbe vous êtes servis alors ça a
commencé par de la discipline
alimentaire
moins de sucre moins de gras peu de
féculents et j'ai rajouté du sport
du sport c'était de la course à pied que
je faisais tout seul 20 à 30 km par
semaine et au fil du temps
1 2 3 amis mon rejoint dans dans
l'exercice et chacune des personnes que
vous voyez sur cette image à côté de moi
n'avait jamais fait de course à pied
avant que je commence aujourd'hui on
fait des courses à pied des demi
marathon presque partout où on peut dans
le monde
alors le point ici est que le fait de
m'aimer moi ou de de vouloir le meilleur
pour moi-même a eu une forme d'impact
sur les personnes qui sont autour de moi
donc on va revenir un peu à l'anglais
après l'espagnol et un peu d'anglais et
what mix you that influence people
c'est ce qui
vous définit ce qui vous fait qui permet
d'avoir une influence authentique sur
les personnes qui sont autour de vous
comme cela a été pardon pour la course à
pied avec mes copains ou pour le Défi
épargne qui permet d'impacter la vie de
10 000 personnes
tout a commencé d'abord par moi donc par
nous-mêmes
la personne qu'on a envie d'être la
personne qu'on veut représenter pour les
autres la personne qu'on veut être pour
tout le monde que ce soit sur les
réseaux sociaux ou dans cette salle
auprès d'inconnu tout va commencer
principalement par nous
on a donc compris au fil de tout ce que
j'ai dit que la discipline est
répétition et constance et que nous mène
vers nos objectifs et que nos objectifs
sont atteignables quand on arrive aussi
à se récompenser sur tout le chemin
on comprend que la discipline est un est
une des plus hautes formes d'amour pour
soi-même la discipline va influencer nos
propres vies et c'est pour cette raison
que
aujourd'hui mon plus grand héritage que
je veux laisser à mes enfants sera
l'amour et la discipline
merci